before Bruce Lee
this looks like a
I'm going to leave it alone okay this
one you can write the joke for this at
home
for Bruce film fighting was mostly John
Wayne punches yes big round right yeah
and now Bruce introduced the kicks yes
so this is a roundhouse kick because you
know kicks are obviously a little bit
more difficult since we're not using our
you know our hands we use more often yes
so I'll show you the power of a kick and
then we'll we'll practice with you okay
okay here we go ready
guys
how'd you do that you take your foot
back
this foot goes back right what happens
well let's try it okay what do I do
Bruce also believed that boards don't
hit back you didn't have been training
with wood so would you like to try a
kick on a person yes I would love to do
it okay so let's come over here oh it's
not you why isn't it you
it'll be my cousin okay all right let's
get him in here kale
is kale
there's a guy over there
[Applause]
the guy over there
looking pretty good to you huh sir yeah
okay so this is called a power sidekick
it's Bruce's favorite kick it's not
power side our sidekick so this is how
it starts just a quick refresher we've
done this before okay left leg steps
behind you or you can skip up if you're
more comfortable yeah pick up your right
knee and then it kicks out and then you
go out like that you want to get him
make sure you got to lift your knee lift
your knees lift your knees okay it's
tearing it's carrying in the groin just
come closer to the whole groin area just
come on sort of kill okay right here so
let's walk through up and then bang
that's a little low right you want me to
go up higher I could also go lower
okay all right so up high and then right
there there you go and push through okay
all right so be like water flowing keep
your energy
you ready okay here we go ready yeah
let's start with your rifle right here
okay okay there you go Focus look there
look there why are you looking down the
right okay yeah I got cancer I was
thinking about a movie uh okay
Transformers it was bad three two one go
[Music]
oh no okay okay so I completely miss him
I completely miss him let's try that
again okay okay
[Applause]
so
more torque more torque so meaning when
you're using your leg right now you're
just using your leg right yeah right you
use your upper body and torque into it
okay right okay right I almost thought
of the same thing oh lovers okay here we
go okay and three two one go
thank you
what Bruce that was Bruce Lee also
channeling a chicken
I could tell he helped me out a bit
there that's okay a little bit a little
bit okay yeah so now we're going to
recreate a scene from Return of the
Dragon where Bruce Lee kicked a bad guy
into
um a box wall oh I remember that one
okay Bruce Lee versus the wall of boxes
exactly yeah so now you have four five
people to kick against okay so we're
just gonna go in in succession we'll go
sidekick bounce back that's right kick
bounce back and all the way through okay
all the way through so this is imagine
I'm in a I'm in an alleyway
made of cardboard
and Five Guys with foam and then a sixth
guy who's looks like he's a hitter for
the Boston Red Sox show up out of
nowhere to attack me okay it's perfect
that's my motivation you'll give me a q1
let's start right here okay and action
[Applause]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen